[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
my friend um hello hello hello hola
uh welcome everyone to julicon 2022 my
name is miguel razuzman macedo and it is
my pleasure to welcome everyone to the
first keynote of juliacon 2022.
before that i have some quick notes to
share so that everyone can get the most
out of this conference
first of all i'd like to thank our
sponsors who have generously donated to
keep gilicon growing
we have our platinum sponsors chili
computing relational eye
relational ai and julius technologies we
have gold sponsors intel and aws and we
have silver sponsors invenio labs beacon
biosignals asmr asml g research calling
pumas ai qra computing and jeffrey
sarnoff please keep an eye out for their
talks and note that they have dedicated
channels on discord where you can
approach them
also we're incredibly thankful to our
media partners that's pac publishing
gather town and vercell and our
community partners
wi mlds women in machine learning and
data science data umbrella and our
fiscal sponsor num focus
on that note remember to register
oh give me a second
uh remember to register for julicon on
eventbrite join the dedicated discord
service and ask questions over there
that's where most of our activity will
be during will be happening so if you're
watching us via twitch or youtube don't
be afraid to join us we're a friendly
bunch
to make the experience to make the best
conference experience possible please
note that we're asking everyone to
observe the jeweller code of conduct
throughout the entirety of the
conference on all official channels and
in communications with each other in
those channels
you'll be asked to accept the code of
conduct as when you join the servers
we have much to offer this year so much
that we're collocated with the jump
conference and they'll have a dedicated
track running throughout the entirety of
the conference i'd also like to commend
our conference organizers for making
this the first chili con where languages
other than
english are supported we've had talks
submitted in spanish and hebrew and
we've also facilitated subtitles for the
overwhelming majority of our talks
this incredible amount of free content
would never been possible without the
immense effort of all the people
involved who have submitted talks
workshops birds of a feather mini
symposia and posters
i'd like to i'd like to also thank the
julie khan organizing committee and all
the juliacon volunteers we're extremely
fortunate to work with such talented and
giving people what we get year after
year in july con free content is an
outright
steal so what can you expect during this
conference we have um
there will be there's a live schedule
uh that you can look at on
uh on the julicon.org site there's the
discord chats and please join us on the
gather town
um i'm done talking about administrivia
so i'd now like to transition to today's
main event uh dr liddell's keynote dr
aaron liddell is the chief machine
learning scientist at h2o.ai
the company that produces the open
source distributed machine learning
platform h2o at h2o.ai she leads the
development of the h2o auto ml algorithm
she is also the founder of women machine
learning and data science and co-founder
of our ladies global
julie khan has a long-standing tradition
of reaching out to incredibly talented
individuals in many other programming
language communities as uncle ira said
it's important to draw wisdom from many
different places if you take it from
only one place it becomes rigid and
stale
we're lucky to have dr liddell with us
today so please join me in welcoming her
to the jeweller community please
remember to ask your questions via the
pigeonhole link or in the green channel
on discord we'll monitor our we will
monitor them and raise them at the end
of the talk
dr liddell we're ready for you now
okay let me
make my screen uh full
um hopefully you can
see my screen
um
so yeah thanks for having me at julia
khan this would be actually my first
julia khan
i'm very excited
to
participate um so today i'm going to
uh and by the way if you hear a little
bit of whining in the background that's
my dog hopefully he's behaves himself uh
well during this talk um
the
title of my talk today is apis and
community building for success so
kind of the goal of um this talk is to
you know i'm coming generally from i
consider myself part of another language
community i'm more in the r and python
community although i will talk a little
bit about my history with julia
um
and so i think my goal today is to
draw on some of the uh
things i see as
successful trends in the other language
communities and hopefully you can
i i know julia is doing a lot of these
things already but i'm going to
highlight some of the things that i
think are important for
success of a language and just generally
success of like any open source
tool itself so
um so yeah the the talk is divided up
into a couple different sections so
first i'm just going to give a little
bit of an introduction because
you most of you may not uh know who i am
if i'm kind of coming from an outside
community uh so i'll give you a little
introduction of my background
um then i'll talk a little bit about the
kind of language wars
thing that happened sort of in the r and
the pipe versus python communities so
that i would say that's
you know mostly a thing of the past but
i'm just gonna sort of highlight that as
something to kind of avoid as we enter
like another uh language that is kind of
similar to these other two at least in
the
machine learning and data science space
um i'm going to talk a little bit just
about the history of
languages as interfaces
specifically to other languages and and
tools
and then
i'm going to talk about multi-language
software stacks so that's
one of my focuses at h2o which is a
multi-language software stack
i'm going to talk a little bit about why
i think apis are more important than
benchmarks so
just the general experience that you
have with a language or with a tool
is you know primarily focused on the api
experience
um
and then lastly i'm going to touch on
community which i think is a hugely
impactful piece of any software package
or language
and their success
okay so
so why am i here so that was kind of a
question i had when i was invited uh to
to speak because you know i don't i'm
not a big person in the julia community
so i you know
was
wondering myself why why am i invited to
speak at this talk um so
you know i guess this is a tradition of
inviting people outside the julia
community but um you know i have some
experience uh with julia so i have
used julia um i guess i mean almost i
guess eight years ago nine years ago now
um
i yeah i first encountered julia in grad
school and i you know kind of
immediately
loved it and
and this was also um you know after
working with some other languages like c
plus
um
i you know and also python and r and you
know really when you're in grad school
when you're doing research and you're
you know under a lot of time pressures
and other things like you you really
want to be efficient with your
programming languages except especially
if that's kind of the focus of your your
research so to me it was immediately
like oh this this makes a lot of sense i
see why they want to build this um
i like it and i want this to become
the new python or the new r um so that
was yeah kind of my initial experience
with julia which i'm sure a lot of
people here can relate to
um
so just a little bit about my other
background so i'm i'm quite involved in
in the python and r machine learning
communities
um i guess especially r but um but also
python as well
um i have kind of a history of
writing machine learning packages
in
mostly r
i do some work in python as well related
to benchmarking
and yeah i mean
now i work as the chief machine learning
scientist at h2oai and so i'll i'll say
a little bit more about what that is
later but
um
you know we we are a multi-language tool
so we have a python api and an r api
um and i work in both of those languages
regularly
um
and
also yeah i have a long history of
community organizing i've been
organizing meetups for over 10 years um
in the machine learning community
um
and
i think was
one of the organizers of of
i i don't know if it's the first machine
learning meetup ever but one of the
first ever uh meetups uh in san
francisco uh was a a small machine
learning group um
back in like 2008. so
yeah i i've loved i've always kind of
been a community organizer and it's
something i really enjoy um
and i will also talk more about that
later
okay so yeah i mentioned that i have
worked with julia before and
kind of came into it like probably a lot
of you
do either through grad school or some
other
experience where you're kind of
you know in a very investigatory phase
of your life trying lots of new things
um i had i think recently i don't know
if this was before after i think it was
before i discovered julia had taken a
computer science course
um
my background is statistics but i also
took computer science courses in grad
school and so i took this
c plus course for machine learning
basically and
i mean it was really quite painful i'll
just be brutally honest it was
really hard um especially coming you
know i'm a statistician i'm not a
computer scientist so
i'm coming from a background of you know
languages like r and python and
you know it's it's a whole another level
of thinking that has to happen on top of
just writing code that makes sense so
um it's yeah it's hard and
the goal you know i think in me learning
that at the time was i wanted to find
out how to write algorithms that would
be fast uh because i did understand
there were limitations in in like
native r and python in terms of what you
could do with speed
um
i think also around the same time i
worked at a startup that was
building a very fast random forest
implementation in c plus it was an old
startup called wise io that doesn't
exist anymore but basically i saw also
wow they're able to make this extremely
fast implementation of random forest
with like a really really low memory uh
compared to
what else was out there for random
forest at the time so this is also like
early 2010s when people were
you know more excited about things like
random forest and and not deep learning
so anyway for me it was really like a
dream come true i i
thought it was amazing um
the code that i wrote was highly
parallelized so
i just remember
learning how to
make something parallel and just sort of
it was just
trivial really like you just uh there's
there's no
learning about all the different um
ways of parallelizing things are in
particular especially at that time had
like several different ways for
paralyzing things uh python also does as
well
um
but one of the things i first ran into
of course at this time of like 2013 the
ml the machine learning ecosystem was
very immature um i remember the first
kind of
roadblock that i got to was i was
you know i had discovered the glm net um
package so
thank you to simon who
uh
made that um which is basically a
wrapper to the uh the fortran code that
is
uh also in the r glm net package um so i
discovered that package it was something
i was familiar with from r i thought it
was great and easy to use but then i
went to sort of evaluate my models and i
couldn't find an auc function anywhere
um i think there was maybe one somewhere
on github that didn't quite work um so i
yeah so immediately i was like okay i
see
where this could go but you know we're
we're a long way away from having the
maturity of some of these other
languages
um so despite that i was able to
still use julia to to do my research so
one of the things that i needed to do
uh is that that i developed a new method
for um
constructing confidence intervals and
in order to prove that it was actually
working i needed to verify that so i had
to basically
you know there was a hundred thousand
machine learning models that i needed to
train quickly i needed to create the
data
and then
train the model measure
uh some metrics and see whether
uh or not the confidence interval
actually contained like the the real
value that it was uh
uh producing so
this uh was successful i was able to
fully use julia for this and i yeah was
just really
really not sure how i was gonna do this
in r with the state of the parallel um
situation at the time so
i probably could have done it in r if i
was forced to but i think also i was
excited to try something new
so anyway i i'm a huge fan of julia i
haven't been using it consistently over
the past you know eight or nine years
i've you know gotten a job and basically
am
sort of required to use r and python
mostly um every day so
uh i would love to have an excuse to use
it more often though
all right so that's kind of like where
i'm coming from
um
so i just want to talk a little bit
about what i call the language wars
that's not my term i'm sure other people
have used that term as well it's just
kind of this thing that happened i would
say in the 2010s um kind of as data
science is gaining popularity um there
started to be this all this like you
know r versus python r versus python
lots of blog posts everybody has an
opinion
uh you know
it's a very binary thinking which i
think is just
very outdated in all aspects but
um
so you know i i want to sort of
introduce this as like a warning to like
let's not
end up doing some of this stuff with
julia because i think um and i and i
haven't seen a lot of it i've i have
seen some benchmarks that that's you
know
benchmarks are useful benchmarks are
important but it's not
um
you know i just don't want to see a
whole another decade of like you know
julia versus python this and that it's
there's there's room for for everybody
really and um
i think it's just kind of like a waste
of time to have these discussions so um
you know some
sometimes you do have to make a choice
you know let's say you're a new data
scientist you're trying to figure out
what are you going to do
what are you going to learn you you have
to learn probably one language first it
does make sense when you're a new
data scientist to kind of at least
somewhat try to master one language
before kind of moving on to another and
um
i think that is a valid question what
what should you learn first um so maybe
we could just keep the discussion to you
know that type of helpful
uh narrative um
but you know some there's very some
negative stuff going on back in the day
just a lot of python people making fun
of the r language which i think is just
very
uh juvenile and
um a lot of uh a lot of the um
uh you know narratives about that
weren't actually even correct so they
would say oh r is slow for this and you
can't productionize r like none of that
is actually true so
anyway it was just a big waste of time
um so i and i think that sort of
language wars kind of really focus on
like the wrong things so i think uh you
know this kind of like my thesis of the
talk so what do i think is probably the
most important thing when you're
choosing a language or when you're you
know using a language every day i think
like
what is the how easy it is
to use the language and that is a
function of like what apis are
accessible and what they look like and
how clean they are and how maintained
they are and how extendable they are um
and then also just the community like
what is it like to work with people in
this community is it unpleasant are
people
uh not nice are people um you know not
helpful uh or are you know you feeling
welcome do you feel like you want to
every day you know
get back on your laptop and start
working on
you know this this new language um i
think that those are the things that
make much more of an impact on like
your actual experience with that
language
um
and i mentioned this already but like
you know a lot of these narratives are
built on sort of false
information anyway
um you know if you want to look more
into some of these
ideas um our studio has a blog post
actually i was just
informed that our studio has a new name
and they are no longer called our studio
anymore but
uh i made these slides before uh
yesterday or before today so
uh we'll just call it our studio for now
um
so yeah i mean a lot of these myths are
not even true it's sort of like oh you
can't productionize this or you know
this is
it's too complicated to have multiple
languages in one you know setting and i
i actually don't find that that is true
and i think a lot of people don't as
well
um so i just kind of want to emphasize
you know you don't really need to pick
one language it's not
really a competition
you know obviously you can only type
one language of code at a time uh but
you know it's it you don't have to
identify with one language you don't
have to be an r person or a python
person or a julia person you can be like
all those things if you like
um and i will also point out that most
experienced data scientists know at
least you know a little bit of of both
and i think that will also be the case
in the future for julia as well i think
you know there will always be um
a use in in knowing multiple languages
so um another point i'll make is you
know in in this modern era in the 2020s
it's it's very easy to use multiple
languages in a single data science stack
so
um that was a little bit harder back in
the day um
you know just getting environments to
work properly and having all the version
numbers match up and things like that
it used to be a little bit harder but
now now it's really not that hard and
um yeah there's just you don't need to
you kind of choose one or the other so i
would say like let's just talk about you
know all the useful languages are python
julia i i'm focusing mostly on r and
python of course there's
many other languages c plus plus java
but because i'm a machine learning
person
um i'm just gonna kind of narrow the
focus and the scope to to those as well
um okay so
next let's talk about like interfaces so
what is an interface so
um
this is uh um a slide from
uh john chambers um
user 2014 keynote so if you're not
familiar with uh john chambers um he's
the sort of main
developer of the s language um which is
the precursor to r which i will explain
on my next slide um
but basically he had kind of this idea
like you know at the time so this is um
like in 1976
he was using fortran so this is you know
you know still very efficient language
definitely not one of the most easy to
use languages uh
the api is
is not in intuitive and not easy to use
so
he had this idea of making what he
called an interface language um and it
was just a way to
abstract the code so that it was more
useful user friendly
um
and this is kind of
uh his kind of original sketch so he
showed this in the talk as well so he's
just this is really kind of one of the
first instances of somebody saying okay
we have this like very efficient code um
that's you know optimized for certain
things
but
what can we do to make it easier so
let's wrap that language basically so um
so this is kind of his first
sketch of of what the interface language
would be
um
and from that he then created the s
language so that is yeah um
the precursor to r so s is s was not
open source
um
r is and that's
the main difference um but yeah it's
basically um
having most of the functions that um
uh
sorry it has uh most of the functions
that that were important um
in fortran basically that he thought
were important in fortran he made
interfaces in s and then that continued
into r and really his his goal um was
as he as he states to turn ideas into
software quickly and faithfully so
um
that is you know that's
centered on the user experience how do
we do this more quickly how do we make
it a more pleasant experience and if you
haven't seen his talk
the link below um
will take you there it's a very good
talk he's a very wise person who's seen
a lot of
development of of languages over time
especially statistical languages
um so then what about python so where
did that come from so this is you know
another
sort of language we're focusing on today
so basically you know as stated by guido
van rossum he's saying uh you know
really the goal was to make a language
that was sort of readable in english so
that when you're reading code you can
actually understand it without you know
having to
a massive number of comments to explain
what each function does and
you know
primarily probably that would be a
comparison to c plus which is not super
readable in most cases so
um and he you know this is a quote by
him kind of describing
how he decided to go about doing this he
says it was kind of just this hobby
thing that he thought might be fun and
he was also involved in this
language called abc it was an interface
to i can't remember what that the
acronym stands for off the top of my
head but basically he was involved in
that language he saw some of the
limitations there and then he kind of
iterated on that and
and created python
so um
let's move on to julia so there's a
great blog post uh that explains exactly
why julia was created so
um and i think anybody who uses julia is
is probably aware of some of the
advantages and some of the um features
that as compared to like
r or python or or c so it's designed to
be as as fast as c with the dynamism of
ruby inter like both interactive and
compiled
general purpose so that's you know kind
of to be like python as well good for
stats and math that's to be like r um
distributed they mentioned hadoop in
their blog post so they really like um i
mean a lot of uh things kind of started
off
um so for example r didn't start off to
be a general purpose language it started
off to be an interface to
you know highly optimized fortran code
python started off as just a way to have
a general purpose language that you
could read so i mean we all have um
there's there's reasons why each of
these languages are formed and and
really like julia and why they created
it has probably one of the most
comprehensive and
uh compelling
um
stories about why it was born um because
we all are aware of
you know there are some trade-offs that
you have by using r or python or c
um
and
uh julia the the authors the co-founders
of julia said they were greedy they
wanted it all so that was their goal and
you know i think
even with very early versions of julia i
think they have achieved uh that so
um
so yeah i think
this is a very you know broad important
effort and if it all does pan out
there's you know
a very compelling reason to use julia
for a lot of things
um especially in my background in like
the machine learning space or data
science space
okay so uh let's talk about
multi-language software stack so this is
like very common these days um
and i'll just kind of highlight a couple
of the interface
packages so these are the different ways
that you can call one of these languages
from another
um
there's probably some on here that i
don't know about i just was kind of
searching
online to see what what came up um
the
the r package for calling julia um one
of them is called xr julia that one's by
john chambers so i would i would guess
that that one is is pretty good uh julia
call i think was the first one in 2017
julia connector i think is 2019. i i
don't know when uh xr julia came about
but
um
yeah i mean i think people see
especially the our community we've
always been a community where we are
wrapping around
highly optimized you know computation
code like c plus c or fortran so it's
just very natural to think that r would
become another interface to julia um and
i think that is great um
so
um in the machine learning world so you
know most most packages these days are
multi-language so you know there's
there's a lot of python packages in in
for machine learning um but of course
most of them are you know the the
hardcore computations are not written in
python they're written in c plus plus or
something else so
um for example tensorflow is primarily c
plus it has a python interface
um and then also via our studio there's
an r interface um same with torch
um of course scikit-learn is also mostly
c plus when it comes down to like
actually doing the computations
and then i'm just gonna mention h2o as
well because we also fit into that
category so
h2o uh is is actually written in java
and has uh python r and scala interface
um
so this is very common and so if you are
developing code in julia this is maybe
something that you want to think about
like
what you know i there is i know a lot of
wrapping already of good packages in
julia but i think you know there's
always
room for more um
so i'll just mention this my one kind of
h2o slide because i obviously know this
uh package better than any any any of
the other ones
um
so just kind of a quick overview of what
that is so we have distributed uh
multi-core and multi-node
implementations of
all all the popular machine learning
algorithms and
automl so
primarily what i work on now is
automatic machine learning and i'm the
creator of the h2o automl algorithm and
i've been working on that since about
2017.
so quite a few years now um
everything's written in high performance
java so people maybe sometimes think
java hey that's maybe slower than c plus
plus why did you choose that um they're
really comparable in this case like we
uh
one of the people that was the
co-founder of h2o was the creator of the
java hotspot compiler which is like a
thing that basically makes java very
fast so he
really knew how to use java in a way
that made it uh equivalent in terms of
speed to c plus plus so
um
yeah and and i mentioned there's apis in
r python and scala
also web gui
and one of the uh unique things about
hjo as opposed to something like a
scikit-learn is it was originally
designed to be like production
used in production by enterprises so
everything was focused from the very
beginning on how do we deploy models and
how do we make them fast in production
and it's uh meant to work in a
distributed fashion as well which is
also something kind of missing from some
of the other
platforms um
so
one thing that i'll talk about real
quick is like how do you maintain
multi-language apis because you know
obviously it's easier if you have one
code base and you just have to work in
one language everything is much easier
but
in the reality is that people want to
have multiple apis so
uh you know that's what you have to give
the people so when they ask um so
there's kind of two ways i would say
that this is done so one is that you
have kind of the the core
uh code base like the main code base
where all the computations are
um and then you have an api maybe in
python for example and then you manually
kind of like
if you if you get a new function in in
the core or a new argument to one of
your functions you would have to then go
into the python api and manually add it
in there
um so that's one way that's obviously
a little bit easier to begin with but a
little bit harder like long term to
maintain
um so i want to just it's kind of make
you aware that there's other ways to do
this so like in h2o we
auto generate the apis more or less not
everything is auto auto-generated but
all the machine learning code is so if
we add a new parameter to an algorithm
um we basically have a process a build
process where it just builds the whole
thing and the apis get built from
scratch every time it kind of checks to
see
okay what parameters belong to this
algorithm if you know if i see a new one
we add it there and
it's much more easy if you're especially
if you're going to have more than one
language um as your additional api
like if you have an r and a python it's
just gonna be a lot easier to to put the
extra effort up front to
basically you know write code that
generates apis it's basically python
code that's like reading the java code
and then spitting out both our code and
python code
so that's just something to think about
if you're starting to do this
um and then there's different ways that
you can kind of communicate between
languages so
in h2o for example we have kind of a
java runtime that's happening where
that's where all the data is that's for
all the computations happening
and actually there's just a rest server
that gets
that's initiated when you start h2o and
when you're typing in in the r api or
the python api you're just actually
making rest calls that say you know
train the you know gradient boosting
machine with this
set of parameters and on this data set
and it's just all you know just
basically
uh json just going back and forth it's
giving the instructions to java java
does the thing and then it you know
sends the information back so there's no
copying of data from like one format
into another everything is just in one
format it's we have our own data frame
uh
construct which is called an h2o frame
and then you know basically r and python
are just accessing the data that way
there's other ways you can do it where
you kind of actually translate the data
from one type to another like maybe you
have an r matrix and that gets
translated to a numpy array
and then when you're using it in python
you know you have all the data types
that you would have in python versus the
data types in r and etc so there's
there's different ways to do it and they
all have different levels of efficiency
um
and this is just like
me saying it would just be so wonderful
to see um
more r python packages that use julia as
the the core computation instead of c
plus and fortran i just think that would
be awesome um
okay
uh all right so then let's just talk
about like why i think apis are so
important uh towards the success of a
language or or a package um
so a lot of times you know this goes
back to the blog post people always
making blog posts about things that you
know don't really need to be
blogged about but like there's there's a
lot of um
there's a lot of uh
speed comparisons so you know how fast
can you load a csv file in r versus
python or julia or whatever so
um i while i think that is useful
information i think it's just one piece
of information that you would want to
take
um
into consideration when you're making a
choice what language or package to use
so
i think there's a lot of focus like
overly focus on
speed as like the be all and all of like
language superiority and
um you know there's uh
you know i'll just remind you there's a
lot of like machine learning packages
for example that are kind of dead now
that were super fast super efficient but
there was
you know the api kind of sucked or maybe
the community didn't really you know
evolve or whatnot so you know there's
there's many many especially c plus
packages
um for machine learning that kind of
just you know are
a relic of the past because they they
did not embrace kind of
what i think are the more important
things of um
of a package or a language you know the
api in the community so
some of the things that i would say are
are
important to consider so you know how
readable and extensible is this language
or package um
the the concept of like how quickly can
you get an idea um into an
implementation so that was of course the
original inspiration with john chambers
in r
what does the package ecosystem look
like and the experience um you know can
is it easy to create a package and
upload it um
you know there's
there's
uh criticisms of of the r community in
the in cran for that being such a kind
of
uh un
helpful fun process so you know there's
there's lots of things that are
important um
visualization you know i think
both are
julia and python all are
you know making you know good
progress in these areas there's lots of
visualization um libraries already in
julia that are very similar to the r in
python
but also just the apis of those
visualization like
functions um let's you know consider how
easy it is to make visualizations
um and then of course documentation and
help that's all part of like community i
think all of that is is important if you
can't get good help and you don't have
nice people to talk to then you know
that's no fun and nobody wants to use
your package or your language
um and then let's kind of move back
quickly to kind of machine learning and
um you know let's look at some of these
popular packages so let's look at
scikit-learn you know that's
like definitely hands down the most
popular python machine learning library
um then we've got tidy models also the
most popular machine learning library in
r and then of course i'm gonna throw h2o
in there just for fun because you know
that's my expertise again um so like
what are what are some of the things
that you would consider um
so how clean is the api is it is it um
you know one interface for all the
algorithms i mean that's basically
essential at this point you need like a
single interface you don't want to have
a different interface if you're using
one algorithm or another
that's just like standard at this point
um that didn't always used to be the
case before scikit learn came along we
had like you know hundreds of different
random you know python packages with
different things that made it very
difficult
to do you know real data science which
requires you to do lots of experiments
with lots of different algorithms
in a very
organized manner so
um you know before tidy models there was
the carrot package in r which is also
the kind of
uh scikit-learn of r
where it has a consistent interface to
all the like mess of our machine
learning packages that exist outside of
that so that's really just you know the
bar at this point um and then like what
are the capabilities of of actually
doing the whole data science
pipeline so
you know data science isn't just
training a machine learning model it's
processing the data it's
doing the data processing and the
machine learning in a pipeline with
correct validation strategies it's
uh doing visualizations after you get
the models it's all of that so how can
we sort of like what is the scope of the
library it it's not sort of good enough
just to do machine learning and training
um
and then another thing that is important
that's
you know i think
has was a was a goal with h2o from the
beginning um
to you know make it easy and efficient
to productionize models
both psychic learning tidy models are
kind of coming at that as a sort of an
afterthought but i think there's been a
lot of progress there um but really like
you need to kind of think about that in
advance and so i think
like
with julia for example we need to think
about like what what's the machine
learning what's the ml ops thing for
julia and how do we make sure that if
you know
people can use all this stuff that they
can actually use it into production
because we don't we want people to be
using it in in the real world um and
then of course documentation and
community is important as well again and
so you know in in julia we have uh mlj
as kind of the prominent
sort of meta package for machine
learning um so it's great that kind of i
mean
i don't know if there uh is you know
controversy of you know should there be
a different one or should there be more
than one but
i do think it's
it's
good for the community if there's kind
of one main
uh api like and everything could be sort
of based on that api you know kind of in
psychic learn too so we have
scikit learn the package and then we
have psychic learn compatible you know x
y and z packages and i think it really
just makes everything easier if um it's
consistent so
again this would be like
good to kind of look at with mlj like
making sure you're kind of ticking all
the boxes
uh there
um
so then i want to talk a little bit like
what do i think is more like modern
machine learning so you know
scikit-learn has been around for for a
long time so we've already you know
reached that sort of point in evolution
of the machine learning like tooling
where we have a single interface that
was a huge step um
from not having one and now i think
we're kind of moving towards like
okay now we have all these tools to do
machine learning how do we make it like
still a little bit easier and so that's
what i've been working on is automl um
there's lots of automl libraries in
python not so many in r but
definitely quite a few in python
um and like what is what are some of the
benefits of that so we've got um
uh we want to automatically train and
evaluate models that's kind of the
obvious thing
some side effects of that is like faster
experimentation so
you don't have to write a whole bunch of
code every time you're trying something
new you just basically use one line of
code
that also helps with reproducibility if
you just have you know a single function
versus a whole bunch of different ways
that you can configure things together
um
it also lowers the barrier to entry for
people that are you know not familiar
with every single machine learning
algorithm and how to use them and how to
tune them um and then i think you know
the baseline performance of automl tools
is quite good at this point so
i think uh this is kind of a natural
like you know future like in julia if um
you know you start thinking about how to
do automl um another thing i think is
important and not to be overlooked is
you know we've spent all
you know a decade or more in the machine
learning community of like
getting really good software and like
all this stuff to train models and to
evaluate models but we
are kind of
now seeing like some of these new ways
to evaluate models pop up so it's not
just like how accurate is my model it's
how explainable is my model or how
interpretable is my model and like is my
model fair on different
subgroups of people when i'm you know
training on
data that represents populations so
there's
little tool kits popping up here and
there in python especially also in our
r has a lot of explainability tools a
few fairness tools but
everything is sort of like third-party
independent there's not um
like psychic learn doesn't have an
explainability toolkit or a fairness
toolkit there are ones that are
compatible with the scikit-learn
interface but i think um and i think
this is good for now like i think all of
this is still kind of in development and
experimental so i think it makes sense
sort of um
[Music]
let's just go to the next slide like it
i think it just kind of makes sense in
terms of julia like for all of this
stuff to kind of happen independently
first i think rather than like the mlj
team saying okay we're gonna um
we're gonna make an automl algorithm and
that's the automl algorithm i think
that's kind of the wrong approach i
think there should be uh multiple
things that happen in that in that space
and then kind of
make them all mlj compatible so that
then at some point you know maybe there
is kind of a default one there or
something but
automl isn't the same as like
implementing a gbm where there's kind of
like one a few sort of correct ways to
implement it there's it's sort of an
evolving thing that's always getting
better over time so we don't want to
ever say like this is the automl we want
it to be
flexible and you know staying up to date
with research and and stuff like that so
i think for now it kind of makes sense
for that to be kind of outside mlj i
mean i'm not
in charge or making any decisions just
kind of giving my opinion um
and then also like it would be great to
see some explainability tools and julia
and perhaps those exist and i don't know
about them yet but um
i think
fairness is another thing more
visualizations that can help with
explainability and then just these other
topics that i mentioned like production
deployment um ml ops all of that so i
thought all of that seems like good
stuff to to work on um
all right so lastly i'm just gonna
mention community
um
so i think i've said this kind of
already but i think community is
probably one of the most
like if if not the most important aspect
of the success of a language or software
package so
um by community like what does that mean
so that could mean like what is the
package ecosystem like
um
how easy is it to contribute to
open source packages or
to get involved in contributing to
either the core
of the language or you know popular
packages
um what's the documentation and help
like even on stack overflow what's the
vibe are people mean are they not mean
like you know that
are there nice like
you know
slack groups or discord or discourse or
you know how is how is the how is the
vibe i guess basically
is it inclusive or not is that are there
diverse voices being represented at all
levels so one one issue that we have
in our community is that we now have
like a lot of diversity in terms of the
users but there's still kind of an elite
group of you know mostly men who run
uh kind of our core and so that's kind
of problematic and you know it's it's a
hard thing to unwind once it's been that
way for a long time so it's just a lot
of work
to
kind of tack that on after the fact so
julia's in a great position to like
really make this important from the
beginning and really get people involved
in just in the core stuff not just like
random package x is created by you know
underrepresented person it's really
getting those people um integrated into
all levels including the leadership of
the language
um
yeah so
and i'll just mention two communities
that i'm a part of so i'm a co-founder
of our ladies global
um
there's
uh
as of today 88 000 members 218 groups
worldwide and we are bigger than the our
user group uh community actually at this
point so
i think this is a really good use case
to follow in julia um
because
you know i would say that the community
of r is is
really really represented by by our
ladies global like there are our ladies
in general they're really um
active in the community so much that we
have twice as many user groups as the
regular our user groups at this point um
and we only got started in 2016. so this
little graph here is is the number of
chapters over time so you'll see kind of
this line in the middle that's when we
um
got together at the usar conference in
2016 and said like let's make this group
and like let's we're hearing people
wanting to start chapters like let's
support that and let's like make that
happen so after that there's like really
explosive growth like worldwide and so
you know maybe i know there's a
presentation about uh julia gender
inclusive uh today so you know maybe
this can be the year where you guys you
know put yourselves out there and like
it's gonna be explosive growth from
there on and i think that like
uh people in these underrepresented
communities can do far more for your
language than you like even expect
because if you sort of accept accept us
we'll be so happy and that we'll do so
much work to like make this successful
and i think that's what's happened with
r in the in the past like
six or seven years is like really we
have embraced that we have been given a
seat at the table and we are really
included and
um it feels really good to put in all
this work to make the language popular
and so i think that's like the best
untapped resource that you have i think
in any
community is getting these people that
you know don't have alternatives you
know maybe the
c plus community is not that great i'm
not saying anything about it i don't
know but like
if there's um you know if you're the
community which is accepting these
people the most that's that's gonna be
those are your advocates um so highly
recommend like supporting julia gender
inclusive um then i'm going to mention
this other group that i started that's
called women in machine learning and
data science so this is language
agnostic it's just general like
basically diversity inclusion meetups
for people interested in machine
learning and data science so this is
another group that like
julia people could get involved with and
you know having meetups in in in here
and kind of just promoting julia and um
i'm happy to facilitate that
um
and then of course julia gender
inclusive i have to have a slide on them
so
they had their um announcement and in
june 2021 that they are you know here we
are
and here's what were
why we got formed you know here's what
we want to do so some of the current
activities that i've seen is there's you
know talks at julia khan and birds of
feather at julia khan and they're doing
some online meetups um so maybe you know
they're just getting started so like
here's some maybe ideas for the future
so
of course it's still you know a pandemic
so we're not doing a lot of
uh you know in-person meetups
at this time so you know maybe when the
time is right to kind of
reach out to local um groups and kind of
establish like local chapters of of this
organization i think right now
everything is online which is makes
total sense for now but in the future
you know when there's more
um
growth and it would it really is fun to
have like a global village of
of people and you meet so many
interesting people from all over the
world
and then one thing i think it uh our
ladies does a great job of is like
recording a lot of the content from the
meetups and sharing it on youtube so
even if you miss the meetup like you
know capturing that content and like
reusing it over and over just sort of to
promote the group and you know you're
also giving free content and it's uh you
know maybe try to make the effort to
kind of capture
this content that you're making and
preserve it and to kind of reuse it as
much as you can
one thing that i don't know if they
would be interested or not but
i think
i know that julia has like a discourse
where a lot of the chat goes on
might make sense to have a private chat
space for julia gender inclusive i don't
know if they have announced that or not
or if that's in the in the works um it's
just kind of nice to have a private
space where you can
you know be more open with
you know your feelings about things your
frustrations because a lot of like it's
quite frustrating to be
a minority in data science and machine
learning or in tech in general or just
in the world in general so having people
to share kind of like
frustrations with too is is important
and i think that's uh you know something
that's it's a positive thing you can
connect and like work on how to improve
you know at least what you can do to
improve the situation
and then also just really get involved
in like the
the larger meetup community um
and you know
tell people about what you're doing and
have joint meetups and kind of use some
of the existing infrastructure to kind
of bootstrap your own community
um so this is kind of what i would say
for like to-do lists for community like
one other idea is kind of
run workshops to on onboard on
underrepresented uh folks into
contributing to julia projects um and
core so
um
so reshma over at data umbrella has done
a number of
uh
psychic learn um
workshops where
she helps to get people
contributing to psychic learn and this
has been you know very successful so
things like that
um maybe add julian inclusive to the
community page i see it's like maybe not
one of the
top level things on the page maybe like
make a whole you know section for it on
the page and then just kind of make sure
community is kind of a top level
priority of the julia language and then
i think everything will just kind of
happen naturally and i think you know
the there's a really
bright uh future for julia so
i think that is it
and i guess i we have probably about
maybe 10 minutes for questions
so i will stop there
thank you dr liddell
i think we're gonna move on to the um q
a
so for people who haven't asked their
questions on the
pigeonhole link i'll be looking at those
and in the green channel on discord
so
people can vote up and down on the
questions
um so i think i'm gonna ask for the most
top-rated question uh when can we get an
h2o.ei api in julia
oh i thought you'd never ask um
i mean
we have definitely talked about it i
mean uh at h2o a number of times um
i
i mean i don't know that we were gonna
like develop one internally um but i
think if there was interest to do kind
of like an open source collaboration
like that would be awesome
um we are doing more like
third-party integration so i just you
know worked on the integration with h2o
into tidy models
um so that's kind of a new exciting
thing that's been kind of two years in
the
like been talking about it for these two
years so now that that's sort of you
know you know check that off the list
like i i would love to do that and if
anybody is interested let me know
because um i don't think we're going to
be able to do it
at h2o and devote like h2o staff and
resources to doing it unless a customer
uh asks us to do it that's how we
prioritize things but if there is an
interest in either
including it in one of the existing
julia like machine learning libraries or
just having its own interface like
definitely
uh let me know especially like would be
awesome to get automl um in julia
all right
let me see if i missed anything on
discord
no just a lot of people thanking you for
the presentation i enjoyed it a lot
i also want to give a quick shout out to
the julia gender inclusive because they
do host a private slack that you
mentioned there is such a forum and you
can contact shien or the judy gender
inclusive uh group to gain access to
that so they've done a lot of good work
and they will continue to do this so
um all right i think i see the next
question
here
um
give your given your community
organizing experience any suggestion on
what the community can do to you know we
already yeah you talked quite a bit
about that but uh there was one thing
that you did mention which is the next
question which is what are some ways
that users of julia can do to avoid the
language wars we obviously want julia to
say we also want to say julie is great
without saying bad things about the
languages
um yeah i mean that's a good question
because i i mean kind of in the founding
of julia one of the goals is to like do
all the things sort of
and excel at all the things so there's
sort of a natural like you know
comparison to be made but
um i don't know i think it's like a
healthy
discussion to compare different you know
use cases and i think i would say just
rather than making broad statements like
julia's better than r julia is better
than python and say like let's compare
how julia you know machine learning
compares to psychic learn and like what
are some of the pros and cons of you
know whatever because
maybe if julia in the future has the
ability to kind of you know outperform
some of these existing frameworks or
tools like it is still very immature in
that way so there are you know there are
some drawbacks to using julia for things
right now at this point but so just
having those conversations and having
them get updated over time and say you
know the last three years we've seen
like a lot of progress and julia doing x
and so now we think it's kind of on par
with
psychic learn or whatever um yeah i mean
there's there's it's good to talk about
these things it's just you shouldn't uh
just try to like make
you know broad statements like you know
it's like saying i don't know
i decide that like red wine is better
than white wine and like that is the end
of the discussion and like nobody ever
has to
have that discussion again like it's
just kind of a
silly thing so just you know being um
having healthy
you know
positive conversations and not just just
keep the negativity out right
at least being able to recognize like
hey like bar
made a lot of crucial decisions like
having that backwards or interfacing
with 4chan
was a very key design decision like
how did that shape that language and
like what are
how do they design around those
constraints like even if we don't
share all the goals like knowing that
you know
knowing the problems they face and how
they try to get around them like that's
also very useful knowledge talking to
people who are there and did cool stuff
mm-hmm
all right
any other questions we have to hop to
the next session it's cool
um all right
yeah um
thank you very much dr liddell uh it's
been great to have you we hope to still
see around and whenever you want to
learn about julia
here we'd love to have you again
great thanks for having me
all right thank you
uh
we're now going to transition to a
sponsored video by julie computing we're
going to
be playing that shortly
we started julia to solve the two
language problem it has turned out to be
a really powerful idea multiple dispatch
generic programming specialization
differentiable programming and so on hi
i'm viral shah co-founder and ceo of
julia computing
some truly amazing things have been
happening in the world as we've been
faced with unprecedented challenges
we've witnessed vaccines being built
with dramatic speed electric vehicles
becoming mainstream batteries in
everything
our entire industrial stock is
undergoing a major transformation as the
economy decarbonizes
never in our wildest dreams did we
imagine that solving the two language
problem would make it possible for us to
have a small role in these big things
many of you know about our contributions
to the julia language
siml and various parts of the package
ecosystem
today i want to introduce how we are
leveraging these unique capabilities of
julia to build a suite of modeling and
simulation products
hi i'm christopher caucus and i'm going
to share with you how julia sim can
enhance industrial modeling and
simulation workflows so julia sim is a
set of modules provided by julie
computing they are proprietary modules
for
enhancing industrial scale modeling and
simulation workflows i'm going to go
through some of these details some of
these modules if you want a full
overview of what's available please
check out the webinar on julia sim that
describes the the full module set
so the purpose of julia sim is that
maybe you're an industrial user and
you've been seeing how you know these
different equation solvers and stuff are
able to give 100 times acceleration but
you know you don't want to be doing the
research right you know the open source
is made to be expansive anyone can look
at the code everyone has all the options
but if you just want a point-and-click
solution that uses you know the best
choice out of all these different
methods and automatically scales it to
the cloud then julia sim is the project
is is the product for you
so
the julia sim has many different use
cases i'll go through these with the
different modules but essentially there
are use cases for juliusim where if you
have already have a model and you want
to accelerate it if you have uh data and
you want to generate models if you have
uh you know if you if you have models
and data and you want to make the the
two you know work well together there's
all these different modules for handling
these different cases
um so let me go through and highlight a
few of them to showcase how julia sim
you know is accomplishing what what i
described so the julia sim digital twin
generator is a module that's all about
bringing data to physics and based
models so for example if you want to
build say a hvac model or a module model
refrigerant but all you have is the data
that that from
experimental cases
the digital twin generator is able to
take that and be able to generate these
a causal models they can then use with
other physical situations
the julius stem circuit trainer is all
about the case where if you have a large
scale model such as this building model
hvac system power simulation and you
want to accelerate this we can use data
driven techniques to generate a
surrogate so an emulator of the original
model that can then replace the original
model that in a way that is highly
accurate but a lot faster we've shown
that this can outperform uh competitors
by about 570 times
now the julius model optimizer is all
about bringing the techniques for model
calibration and um and and auto model
autocomplete you know the scientific
machine learning and making it automated
so you you bring us a modeling toolkit
model you bring us the data and then
they click a button and say please make
the two line um it can do things like
automatically discover missing possible
missing physics and the parameters that
are then required to be able to do this
calibration
the julius and controls module is all
about bringing model predictive control
directly to to you without
any interference and also make it so
that way it's easy to train pid and
other linear controls analysis um the
codepiler is all about taking the code
from julia sim and the models that you
have and generating code for embedded
hardware so that we could be run in
in real world use cases so thank you
very much hopefully this gives you a
quick overview of the things that can be
done with julius sim if you're
interested please get in contact thank
you very much
thomas qsp is julia computing's product
to do advanced pharmaceutical sciences
on julia hub
it's targeted towards the domain of
quantum systems pharmacology or short
qsp and in this domain we often look at
large large systems that capture for
example a pathway in your body but not
only that pathway but in combination
with for example an organ multiple
organs or the whole organism itself
and the idea is to then test how drugs
affect those systems and one central
objective is always to do that as widely
and as robustly as you just possibly can
and having the wrong computational setup
in qsp can really hold you back in
understanding how the drug works
promiscuousp was designed to address
this issue it provides you the software
environment where number one you can
formulate your qsp studies and number
two run them as well so on the one hand
side it's the software package promise
qsp in julia and the other thing is the
access to the hardware that you will
need which is julia hub and julia hub
can be actually accessed in two
different ways which you both can see on
this screen so number one is the
interactive environment so here you've
got a visual studio instance on the
browser number two will be here over an
extension called julia hub where you can
send scripts directly
so here in our example script we're
actually creating a virtual population
in order to test how the drug affects
these systems for virtual patients and
we do that using pumas qsp and then this
file we're doing it in a linear way
using the terminal terminal down here
but if we now want to use multiple nodes
on julia hub we have to modify our code
a little bit we
we use the package distributed and then
there are a few other modifications that
we all need to do but then we use the
extension of julia hub select the
current file which other files are
needed and then we set up exactly which
technical
features we want to have for our job and
at the very end we then just press this
button called start job and that will
just start a distributed job on julia
hub once it started it will pop over
here in this list of jobs and then on
the very right side you always have this
this
icon on the very right which will bring
you to the logs that give you more
information of what the job is currently
doing
so the last message that you will see in
this logs once your if your job has been
successful is that the job status will
be updated to status completed and once
that has happened you can go back into
this list press the desk icon to save
your results you can also
import your results back into this
interactive environment and then do
further analysis do your visualizations
like in this plot window you used to in
your visual studio instance locally to
really analyze your results and see if
you're happy
with what the analysis has shown you
so as a take home of this very short
demonstration of promote qsp i hope what
comes across is that we're really
focusing on the two things usability and
performance
and one example is how easy we want to
make it to go from a linearized code to
the distributed jobs um there's a lot of
more information of pumas qsp so for
example here on the
help.juliahub.com website pumas qsp you
can find a lot of more information so if
you're interested feel free to check
that out
cedar eda is our exciting new entry into
the analog circuit simulation space that
provides a modern flexible easy to use
high performance analog spice simulator
all in an open framework
to start with we support the traditional
point tool usage model of a netlist in
and wav files out like hspice or spectre
that's where the similarities end
point tools created by our competitors
naturally create silos in the companies
that purchase them making it more
difficult to collaborate and it adds a
lot of drudgery to the engineering
experience with cder it is built on an
open programmable framework which
encourages partnerships between teams
allowing them to build
better products faster
cderson can calculate derivatives of the
design parameters all the way to the
performance measurements using the
latest techniques in auto
differentiation
this enables analog designers to better
understand the important circuit
parameters to improve performance
also optimization and machine learning
with derivatives only require a fraction
of the simulations
also machine learning models that use
differential equations from the circuit
that obey energy conservation laws
are much better as they will not do
crazy things
with derivatives and programmability you
can develop new analysis techniques that
are not bound to the traditional ac dc
and transient analysis types
instead of dealing with circuit
variations with compute intensive random
sampling methods you can create your own
fast quasi-analytical methods for your
application
even though cdersim compiles the circuit
down to fast machine code it has a
modern debugger that allows breakpoints
to be set in verilog a or measurement
source code
and engineers can intuitively step line
by line through the source code instead
of print statements like in the 1990s
cedarwaves handles the details of
continuous time waveforms from analog
simulators and makes it very easy to
make reusable analog performance
measurements and build automations
if a measurement fails the original
signals are automatically tracked and
can be plotted saving setup debug and
simulation time
it supports many of the interpolation
methods for smooth signals such as
quadratic spline or akema interpolation
it can plot signals of gigabytes in just
a few milliseconds all doing this while
using the least amount of memory in the
industry
performance metrics can be associated
with a component and carry along to a
higher level simulation so when the
power consumption issue occurs at the
top level the offending component can be
automatically identified speeding up
days of debug
your teams will sleep better at night
knowing analog tests are passing and the
silos are now working together being
more productive and delivering
predictable results faster
amplifying the creative ability of the
engineers
the fastest simulation is the one you
don't have to simulate
if you're tired of a manual analog flow
of turning knobs and pressing buttons
you and you know you could be more
productive then contact us as we are
working with large key customers
julia hub is at the core of all that we
do it's the foundational infrastructure
for all of our products and it's a great
place for everyone to get started with
julia on our public juliehub.com server
it's here that you can search through
the open source documentation find the
packages that you're looking for and
directly use them within pluto notebooks
and vs code editors where you can build
out the code of your dreams once you're
ready julie hub's there ready to spin up
ad hoc clusters of hundreds or even
thousands of nodes to take your code to
the next level we truly believe it's the
simplest and easiest way to take your
code to a cloud supercomputer for high
performance computing
of course it also comes for enterprise
where we work with your teams to set it
up within your infrastructure to hit the
security requirements that you need or
put it within a dedicated virtual
private cloud
we have complete compliance controls
where you can rest assured with our
corporate compliance through sock 2 and
gdpr's compliances as well as audit
trails that allow you to hit the metrics
that you need to satisfy regulate
regulatory concerns
there are also additional collaboration
tools and more controls that allow you
to ensure that the people that need to
see the code are able to see it and
those that don't need to can't see it
this
authentication and
authorization through your single
sign-on solutions ensures that you're in
control
let's take a look at what the enterprise
server looks like here it's a lot like
our public infrastructure
one difference is as you search through
the ecosystem you're searching not just
the general registry but you can see
there are multiple registries available
to me here and i can go to my team's
registry and look through all the code
that's available there
find packages that i'm looking for and
even look at their documentation that's
built and hosted right here on the julia
hub server with all the greatness all
the great uh
niceties of life that documenter
provides
it's a one-stop shop for everything that
you do and when you point your julia
instances either local or hosted by
julia hub at your julia hub server well
they have access to all of these
packages just as though they were open
source packages so i can pkg.add my
secret analysis
and not even know whether it's public or
private either way my company's ip is
protected and secure within this
dedicated host
we're taking that one step farther with
the latest release of julia hub with the
concept of projects right where
just publishing something to an open
source registry allows you to access it
but it doesn't allow you to collaborate
on and work on it directly and that's
what projects do they group your
resources and even jobs spun up by those
resources in a way that you can work
with and reason on so here's that secret
analysis and i can just open it directly
in my editor it brings up visual studio
code here in my browser and allows me to
start editing right away uh and and i
can look in and start making changes
maybe i want to change the logging
infrastructure a little bit here i can
change that and we believe so deeply in
code
version control that it's built into
this right i'm able to publish my branch
to my internal maintainers where they'll
be able to review it and merge those
changes back into the main development
trunk so that's projects a great way to
work with and and group resources into
access controls
lastly are all of our applications where
we bring out the best of of what's
available here by default we have the
julia editor with bs code pluto
notebooks you can
add your own applications some
dashboards widgets things applications
that are registered within the private
registries also show up here which is a
great way of working with them
given how juilliard is central to
everything we do we will be changing our
company name to julia hub
have a great julia khan and i expect to
see all of you on the chat thank you
all right welcome back um i'd like to
thank our platinum sponsor julia
computing for the previous presentation
we now have our next speaker
from another sponsor aws
stephen heidel is the head of software
development at aws center for quantum
computing stephen welcome
thank you very much and hello everyone
i'm here today on behalf of
amazon web services
aws is thrilled to be a sponsor of this
year's julia con 2022
today i'll be focusing on one really
exciting area of research development
here at aws and that's quantum computing
over the next few minutes i'll give an
overview of quantum computing at aws
i'll also talk about how we use julia
um
to perform our research and then i'll
share some opportunities to to learn
more and try things out yourself um so
just a quick intro to myself i lead the
software team here at the aws center for
quantum computing and i'm calling live
now from san francisco california
uh the aws center for quantum computing
is just one component of a broader suite
of quantum computing programs here at
aws
so
you see the aws center for quantum
computing we also have the quantum
solutions lab
which
work on collaborative research programs
for both quantum and classical solutions
and we have the aws partner network
including
universities and companies around the
world working on quantum computing
alongside us
and we also have amazon bracket which is
a fully managed service you can find on
the aws console for running quantum
computing programs
so speaking of bracket the exciting
thing about bracket is just as an aws
service as any other aws service you can
run it
you can go online and try it out right
now so
um through the aws console you can find
amazon bracket sign up and this will
allow you to build test run and analyze
quantum programs
you can write your quantum programs
using the amazon bracket sdk test them
against
simulators
both local and those simulators managed
through
amazon's compute cloud and
then as a next step run those programs
against real quantum computing devices
offered by our partners such as righty
computing ion q and d wave
finally the
amazon bracket includes a suite of tools
to help understand analyze
and move on to the next steps with the
results you get back from your quantum
computing programs
again this is a service anyone can sign
up for and it's really exciting uh when
i first started in quantum computing it
was
uh five six years ago and it wasn't
there was not this option to just uh
show up and uh and run some programs
that quickly so
um
where i work though is the aws center
for quantum computing
the aws center for quantum computing is
a is a research center based in pasadena
california
and also we have a team here where i am
in san francisco california that works
alongside them
so the aws center for quantum computing
is focused on building
quantum hardware and we aim to be
over the long term build an innovation
center with resources to execute
large-scale um long-term programs within
quantum computing so uh every day we're
doing original research on quantum
algorithms and hardware um and with a
particular focus on quantum error
correction
which is in our opinion the way that we
get to
useful applications for quantum
computing
um
and an exciting thing a new addition to
our research
here at aws and quantum computing is
quantum networking and for some reason
the words aren't showing up on my slide
but i'll read them out for you so
quantum networks will leverage some
technologies already deployed for modern
optical communications um
and the aws center for quantum
networking is going to be an innovation
center to develop new hardware software
and applications for quantum networks
so this will bring quantum network
enabled advances in privacy security and
computational power one step closer to
our customers this is something that was
just announced in june of 2022 um so a
month ago and if you're interested in
learning more about this you can check
out the aws quantum computing blog where
we talk about applications for quantum
networking and key distribution um and
leveraging some existing infrastructure
optical communication infrastructure
in order to send
quantum
states between locations for a number of
different applications
so finally uh julia here at aws quantum
we make heavy use of julia um for doing
quantum device simulations julia's uh
both expressiveness and performance uh
uh
are perfect for application of
simulating quantum devices prior to
actually fabricating them and testing
them in the lab
so we make use of a number of quantum
package or a number of julia packages
that you see here
and also contribute back to them
including quantum optics.jl
quantumcumulants.jl and itensers.jl
um we have a software that uh
communicates between julian python and
we take advantage of both languages in
order to perform our work so
if you're interested actually in some of
these packages uh one of the aws
quantum team members
jacomo torai
he and matt fishman are giving a talk um
at uh 7utc on some of these packages uh
and how they uh make use of julia's
features um
to perform the quantum simulations we
need to perform
and finally the
uh so we take
we make use of those packages here on
the quantum hardware design team so
that's the team that
lays out qubits and creates chips
chip designs for fabrication at the
awsome for quantum computing um and we
are
continuing to grow so if you have an
interest in in julia large scale
simulations quantum simulations quantum
optics or indeed have
run across any of these packages um this
would be a great opportunity to to
explore joining the team uh we are
looking for research scientists software
engineers
and uh and uh people with a whole bunch
of different backgrounds to come
together and fuse julia quantum
computing um in order to uh to build our
next generation of devices so um
uh there's a link there bitly aws julia
khan that will take you to a job
description if you're interested uh some
contact information there for for more
details
and obviously we were very excited to to
meet you and
share more about uh
what we're doing here at the center for
quantum computing and what specifically
what we're doing with julia so um wanted
to keep this short and sweet uh enjoy
the rest of julia khan and uh thank you
very much for your attention
thank you steven
uh and thank you to the folks at aws who
have sponsored julicon
and
that's it for this block i just want to
remind folks to please visit julicon.org
and follow the rest of our activities
see y'all on the discord dispatch and i
wish you the best julie con experience
possible
cheers